it's match time our to Tyler here and
Alan Smith with you as always to
describe it and we're looking forward to
something special today well I think so
Martin I hope these two teams won't
disappoint us well we don't need to
build this one up too much happened - it
speaks for itself Barcelona and Real
Madrid yet one of the clashes in world
football isn't it so many stars on both
sides can't wait for this one
[Applause]
we've seen with the ambitions of Gareth
Bale wanted to leave the family to go to
route Madrid now they can charm even the
great players that their burner bio and
strut their stuff yeah I think it's the
pinnacle of any primers ambition to pull
on the famous white kit they pretty much
done it all and I've been very lucky to
work in this football Cathedral the
stadium that is the Santiago bernabéu
special place Martin isn't it every time
you stand down on a touch line look up
at those steep stands it's a wonderful
sight
at the referee for this important
fixture today Alvaro arias Romero
[Music]
there's top stopping by dre on the trip
and now any está
[Applause]
the attack has done well beating this
man
[Applause]
not need a second invitation visit this
point
and the celebration by Cristiano Ronaldo
he knows how to work an audience doesn't
it and he knows how to be defender super
stuff well he's a shoot to start and
that just sums up his ability what a
ball score
has opened the scoring one Dale here
[Applause]
what's on here and those scraps where
they attack his two feet up from the go
key for that time hung out to the poor
well modrich
[Applause]
raphaël Varane
County crows
a straightforward piece of work for the
goalkeeper he's kept the ball after a
good first touch Sergio Busquets
throwing for Real Madrid
Podrick
provision to be able to switch to play
there
[Applause]
[Music]
Real Madrid given the throw here onto
Ronaldo
Marcela
Cristiano Ronaldo
Oh
[Applause]
they're gonna run it round the trip fail
here comes the support
throw it Caray on the trip
Mockridge
the world's danger but he's cleared it
let's cut out that pass it wasn't an
accident he read the mind of the
opponent Sergio Ramos looking to supply
Cristiano Ronaldo
[Applause]
[Applause]
very good intercepting play there to get
his positional situation right and win
the ball without too much effort
for Real Madrid
[Applause]
he has cleared it well
and now the shot terrific stop it's a
corner coming up yet again
[Applause]
[Applause]
not rich
and here's the shot he's made to save
[Applause]
Maude rich
Iniesta Luis Suarez
even rocket hitch
support action the possessions gone away
okay - we'll get this one no problem
fast learner awarded the throw here
bit of movement by the opposition to
Nick that ball from the throat
[Applause]
talk about how
[Applause]
Tony Krause
Cristiano Ronaldo
and ago people are going to touch to
that fine save the cha-cha
is off the ball free kick now against
Real Madrid
sandhya Bush gets its good work between
these two
foul against Real Madrid referees
reduced the yellow card for Real Madrid
we can have no complaints looking at
that did you see anything cynical in
that album oh that is a clumsy tackle it
really isn't no question it was a foul
[Applause]
DK sergio busquets
[Applause]
Iniesta
trying to find an opening not panicking
and Barcelona on the attack
able to make a good interception
here we've got a free-kick given by the
referee
[Applause]
[Applause]
Cristiano Ronaldo across it undefined
bail
referee's decision is a corner for Real
Madrid
it is that
Johnny CROs cross is in Cristiano
Ronaldo good stop by the goalkeeper
trust it well good jump ahead just off
target daddy's gone for that corner only
just missed it
[Music]
Sergio Ramos
real good contest between these two as
they jostle for possession I'm still
going try and run this Real Madrid given
the throw here
raphaël Varane
Tony Krause
[Applause]
it's really the way to get the ball out
of the danger zone he's got that through
clever reading of the game intercepting
and getting possession back for his team
Gareth Bale
laughs have fun at one Dale so at
halftime the school is one-nil goal came
early it came very early and they never
really looked back they didn't have too
many chances
created against them so now be feeling
confident in that dressing room
[Music]
now settling back down here in the
Santiago bernabéu Stadium
as a bad pass he's giving it straight to
the opposition
Cristiano Ronaldo oh and goes across
that's wonderful and it's a go
the goalkeeper did he's focused but I
think he might have the threats that he
didn't get hold about another angle on
it here
restarting a tuna
[Applause]
city
Luis Suarez Raphael Barratt on to
Ronaldo
[Applause]
good play to see that potential to get
put in and intercept
[Applause]
little messy
Sergio Busquets
[Applause]
on to Ronaldo
[Applause]
spotted teammate and he's got the
technique as well as the vision to
switch to play
[Applause]
Madrid they're just emphasizing their
superiority and widening the margin yeah
I think so and you look at their overall
play and they've deserved it because of
this cape but nothing he caught intended
to go quite as close to because bars he
did he's got his goal that's what
matters
we expected this such a one-sided affair
Scola
Mockridge
now Messi
strong challenge there by Sergio Ramos
[Applause]
it was easy on the eye but in the end
pretty easy to defend against Jordi Alba
that bench Barcelona what to make a
change now
[Applause]
Karim Benzema
Podrick
they've got the ball back Barcelona
even rocket ish
Sergio Busquets
[Applause]
Jordi Alba
but when they do say you've been in
these matches about the psychology of
getting it right on the big day you
would have thought ability wise it's
very much level pegging here but in fact
one side seems far more up for it than
the other yeah it does seem to be the
case whether the managers pumped up
these flyers got them ready better than
his opposite number that seems to be the
case at the moment that aura
Luis Suarez is still a long way to go
but it's a step in the right direction
with this goal
[Applause]
[Applause]
put the ball in the net great delivery
to the box from that left-hand side
where they look dangerous the blue
sliced about time in any time bees
jumped and headed out perfectly and it
is a substitute coming on for an already
booked player
[Applause]
fail
[Applause]
Barcelona awarded the throw here
naughty crows
[Applause]
very well timed up and it is a Barcelona
substitution we're about to see they've
got to try and switch things around
here comes a substitution Tony Krause
Cristiano Ronaldo this could be an
opening for Real Madrid East go the
balls loose goalkeeper made the save but
he couldn't hold it
luis suarez he's stolen it back from the
opposition good tackle
[Applause]
we swap
Santiago's gifts
well that's well white from that angle
and his team mates out happy no and you
don't blame the deal what on earth was
he thinking there
[Applause]
funny crows
[Applause]
towards fail
[Applause]
gerrae PK he really does need to ensure
that this atmosphere is a nasty one
really doesn't affect his game today
Jordi Alba
good passing here shots on here attack
definitely the best form of defending
the lead they've got already
[Applause]
substitute coming up to try and repair
the damage there
possession changes feet
Karim Benzema and Ronaldo
it's a piece of cross good hands
bread-and-butter work really by the
goalkeeper but he did it very
competently he's having a good game
cover house
fail
or looking for that first time finish
all the best tychicus very adept to that
kind of thing and he's not bad but quite
pull it off there
[Applause]
as a bad pass he's giving it straight to
the opposition
20 close
and shoots and well done the goalkeeper
and he's hung on to the ball
[Applause]
we're minutes away from the end 20 crows
opportunity East Oh what's a fine safe
here's the shop the god
I haven't switched off Allen late in the
game and have got another one extended
the lead not letting up the talk show
good for the site and play to them folks
another point goal the keeper is have to
pick the ball after their piece at a
visible time as have the losing side
here
at the end of the game the referee is
called the halt and it has finished here
for one but it turned out to be a
different kind of game to the one
perhaps we set up for you at the
beginning very one-sided yeah you end up
feeling a bit disappointed as a neutral
because we didn't really get a contest
but the winning team won't be
disappointed at all played well
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
you